guys are very but guys that have like
their own weird [ __ ] and it also feels
like you're that's about it for andrew
with weird [ __ ] something weird in terms
of you
remember the movie boomerang yes yes
yeah yeah that made me understand and
what is it about the feet is it just you
want it to be attractive or you go the
way you do anything is the way you do
everything if your feet are taken care
of i know your pussy's on point no
that's some [ __ ] that we add to it
that's not it okay something's weird
yeah well there is a theory that it's
called cathexis that a lot of guys that
are super in defeat or like want to [ __ ]
them
number one the toes look like little
dicks that's like the freudian thing uh
the second one
what's she doing
what you doing you little digging
little baby dick
my it's not even is it even pedophilia
if it's a baby it's a baby day listen
listen
i love it i like feet they look nothing
like dicks
some of them no they don't in what way
what way your toes look like this
phallic-ish yeah that's like the i bet
this is darwin he's a scientist i'm just
passing darwin got everything you said
freud darwin was evolution yeah that's
right you got nothing
wrong nothing
no but then the other one is that um uh
i don't think i don't know this one is
the one i subscribe to whatever it is
okay this is mine just ruin it
hey i'm back
i have a perfect score on wikipedia wait
really
i did i did before
i mean how many people
right now
whose feet are that is not my foot oh
that is my foot okay
yo you're crazy you're crazy
um ah okay whitney what the [ __ ] are you
butt naked in that second what the hell
is happening what oh these are just
photos from like online but you look
butt naked this is your wiki feat
okay if you guys score
yeah five stars still
now what
even with the bloody ass [ __ ] toe
yeah is that joe biden wait why are you
naked there
i'm not naked there i'm in a swimsuit
and i have a watermelon slice on my
[ __ ] oh
we get it you muted me on instagram no i
didn't mute you but
you know when you learn someone's muted
you or does it look good they're like
what is that you're like posted that
seven times in a row i've never seen
that oh yeah i guess there's a lot of
[ __ ] on my feet but these are like
screen grabs of instagram stories or
something 600 total votes on your feet
wow
1022 beautiful
oh 335 nice 170 okay i mean
what is this that's me showing how to
[ __ ] a foot no that's you having a
midlife crisis
by the way
thinking i'm going to live another 30
days
wait you think you're dying young this
is not mid-life uh i don't know it's a
good question
thank you
i [ __ ] hate you
i hate it when people say that to me i
did it to just buy time